so what we're going to do now is I'm
going to prove to you I'm just going to
show you I'm going to prove to you the
relationship that the gradients of these
perpendicular lines has now before just
now I said imagine each one of these
units these own square sorry is one unit
okay that's fine you can imagine that
you'll get a concrete example but as a
mathematician and as mathematicians we
want to do a little better than cut we
don't want to just prove this thing our
perpendicular lines for this example we
want to do it for anything so I now want
you to imagine that those are gridlines
they're not there right so you don't
know any of these distances that's just
some point somewhere off there it could
be one unit away it could be a hundred
units way my point is it could be
anywhere okay just imagine that I'm just
going to put the grid lines back for now
because you guys have grid lines and
also it will help us do the construction
of microphone so let me just change that
back okay here's we're going to do have
you got that triangle there now triangle
we're going to label some stuff on this
triangle now this point a I'm trying to
suggest that it's anywhere it could be
anywhere so I can't say even though it
looks like it that it's at 2 comma 4
because that locks it in position at one
particular spot so instead of saying 2
comma 4 I'm just going to say well let's
use algebra because algebra is the kind
of mathematics that lets us deal with
numbers when you don't know what they
are ok this become really powerful for
us in a minute so I'm just going to call
it x coordinate piece and I'm going to
call its y coordinate Q there just name
it just labels I call them anything I
want I call it a call them you know
Jennifer and Kate or Andrew and make it
not that I work them anyway they're just
labels temporary
now help me able yeah no you're right
that's why I didn't do it now let's look
at the exponent for a second
if the next one is crazy there that
distance is somewhere on this triangle
my question to you is where on the
triangle is it how would you describe a
bourbon without make point you think
it's there what words would you use to
tell me where on the triangle is anyone
many takers everybody ready for Pb okay
I think the base that this guy down here
I think that perfect do you see that
right there
this distance here has to be equal to
peer that's what makes it the coordinate
the x-coordinate P removed P units to
the right so on the triangle the basis
piece is just right angle by the way and
that means if you think about the y
coordinate Q Y is about up and down
isn't so where's Q it's a yeah it's a
political sign I have saw something in
doing with you here so that's this guy
over here that's cute
okay now this is important because I'm
going to take this triangle and I'm
going to ask you to do the same thing
here and I'm going to copy it I'm going
to make a arm a conquer a time you never
Congo means it's not just like now it's
not just alike it's exactly the same
okay now don't try this just yet I've
got my arm it's the same triangle that
you see it just in your time I've got
the same triangle watch what I'm going
to do with it I want to think about
perpendicular lines okay so what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna take this
triangle still same triangle and I'm
just going to rotate it 90 degrees okay
so watch me do that I'm going to spin it
around and it's going to sit there do
you see what I've done
did you watch me rotate it it's the same
triangle just in a different spot and
Lauria is it different
can you draw this triangle print in the
second quadrant I sort of
um can you drop your power line up if
you use 10 then next time is pencil or
maybe just draw one underneath that has
this so I'll give you a minute to catch
up draw your congratulate
what is it
that means if it goes up Sally I'm
setting off my Wi-Fi right now I think
we need folks I think it is folks I
think you need both models yeah gotcha
okay okay so it's okay if you're not
quite finished yet
but most of you are so now let's to help
us understand this triangle over here
cuz it's the king all right do you
remember how you told me on the first
triangle about where P and Q were right
so P and Q we're on the original
triangle that means P and Q are on the
new Congress label because all the
lengths the st. can someone told me
where he is
it's our it's this guy here isn't it
because it used to be a damn key but I
rotated the whole thing so now this
length whoops that like there is pink
you're great yeah okay good by the same
token with that right angle over there
you can tell me the Q is it's the
horizontal like right you can't say
straight cuz they're all straight and
friendly so that guy there is cute right
same triangle just move doesn't stay
with me you too okay now the most
important point is the one that I've
labeled would that be phat dawn okay
since we called the first one cat away
let's call this one capital B now
healthy work out on the basis of what
you've told me about this triangle what
are the coordinates let's do the x1
first horizontally where am i you now
this length is Q but the coordinate is
not cute because look I'm going to the
left
I am horse quite a bit so that it's
negative Q isn't it
negative cute
Thanks that's the x-coordinate what
about the like 1b now have a look it's
above the axis very cool you had to go
up so that means is it's just positive P
okay